hey leute und willkommen zur snapshot
video vom snapshot 12 w 40 adi ist weil
wir das wahrscheinlich schon an meiner
stimme hört wenn ich total krank gewinnt
er heute es auch nicht ich kann nur
durch den mund atmen
mein gehirn ist total scheiße ich kann
mir einfach nicht so gut also müsst ihr
wissen deswegen wird diese snapshot
review heute ein wenig anders ich werde
einfach nur hier ein bisschen rumlaufen
der sieht es ganz interessant und zwar
gibt einfach mal bei euch endlich auf
ihr seht ihn jetzt so sollte leben sehen
ihr sport halt wirklich hier und da sind
überall so kleine inseln aber das ist
relativ egal denn darum geht es nicht
sondern um die änderungen ich habe mir
jetzt schon die version eingepackt aber
ich wollte euch nichts zeigen sondern
das einfach vorlesen weil zeigen uns so
dass mir geht es wirklich nicht so gut
deswegen ist mir egal ob jetzt enorm
hoch oder daumen runter geht aber die
nächste snapshot review wird besser
werden also da kann ich euch dann auch
wieder sachen zeigen und ja es wurden
zum vierten für hexen hinzugefügt das
heißt in sümpfen treten wir hexen auf
und dort haben die jetzt auch kleine
häuschen sowie npcs es gibt eine
flachland vorlage die heißt redstone
ready das mit 52 schichten sandstein
drei schichten stein und eine schicht
grundstein also für redstone videos wie
sie zum beispiel ich mache es plames
park und soweit ganz gut
beim erstellen von superflach velten
gibt es nun die option bäume festungen
et cetera zu generieren
das ist einfach dass er auf einer flat
welt zwar keine berge habt aber trotzdem
ganz viele bäume und so weiter und ihr
kürbis so hohes gras blumen bäume in
schächte dungeons festungen sehen
wüstenbrand und ärzte werden auf
superflach wählten dann ebenfalls
gesprochen wenn ihr die so konfiguriert
das inventar wurde verbessert und zwar
wenn man mit der maus über einen item
fährt moments und einer der tasten 1 bis
9 drückte wird dieses an den
entsprechenden platz in der schnellen
zugriffs leiste gelegt das heißt 123456
das kann ich euch jetzt sogar zeigen wie
cool also das funktioniert super das
finde ich auch richtig toll
der pick blog wenn man mit einem klick
wenn man mit dem mausrad irgendwo drauf
klickt funktioniert nun auch bei items
also ich kann hier einfach mit maustaste
drauf damit sofort ein komplettes
denkens im kreativ modus keine items von
der auswahl leiste in der survival
inventar mit shift klicken verschoben
werden
moment verspürte kreativ so dass keine
items von der auswahl leist industrial
inventar irgendwie so okay da dort
funktioniert irgendwie irgendwie so
keine ahnung wie die das jetzt genau
meinen ich bin relativ gesagt krank mit
einem linksklick können nun keine türen
und falltüren mehr geöffnet werden
so wie keine schalter und knöpfe mehr
betätigt werden es muss die rechte
maustaste benutzt werden das heißt es
kann ja auch bei ihm zeigen ich stelle
der tür hin links klickt ihr einfach nur
ab sieht es eben creative aber ich kann
dir nur noch mit rechts öffnen ich kann
mir konzentriert fc ich habe jetzt gar
nicht wahrhaben dass man ebenso geht
nicht mehr
sandra prechts deckblatt hab dass die
textur das leuchtfeuer blogs und dessen
lichtstrahl wurde mal wieder geändert
moment da ist die textur haben wir da
ich mach das mal ganz kurz hier also der
sich von den vorher eigentlich besser
aber egal jedem den seinen geschmack
einige neue nbc tags für
benutzerdefinierte item namen für
ersteller von welten sind jetzt da also
man kann die dinge verändern
das ist halt so ein web hersteller
gerichtet slime spawn in der nacht in
sumpf billionen also besser zu finden
jetzt mainz und die verbreitung von
feuer in wäldern wurde geschwächt dann
gab es halt noch total viele bugfixes
mal wieder dabei sind auch ganz viele
neue bugs hinzugekommen aber die möchte
ich jetzt gar nicht eine vorlesung weil
ich einfach nur schlafen möchte ich
hoffe ihr respektiert das und die
nächste vorstellung wird besser und naja
bis zum nächsten mal